hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel what today something very
exciting has happened PETA
have done one of those things where they
tell us how video games evil it's
actually the best the weirdest part
about it is that I am a person who is in
support of animals but somehow the way
that Peter does these every single time
I don't know if you guys remember they
made a like a browser-based game called
Pokemon black and blue that was about
how eating and beating up Pokemon is not
okay but the way they do it is just they
can't be serious
you make supporting animals just to me
me it's so weird okay so this is a guide
on how to play Animal Crossing the vegan
way which naturally you should be doing
or you're the scum of the earth it
starts by saying with everyone
quarantined at home and on social media
more than ever by now you've probably
heard about Nintendo's new Animal
Crossing new horizons this vegan guide
to Animal Crossing new horizons will
help answer some of the tough ethical
questions that the game presents does it
as well as give you tips on how to help
real animals while living your island
life first up no fishing what do you
hate animals you can't fish that's not
vegan
you shouldn't fish in real life so you
shouldn't fish in the game sure unlike
in real life the fish and animal
crossing new horizons don't feel pain
and also aren't real but fishing is
harmful to animals and the planet this
is your island it's your job to protect
it reaping the wildlife right out of the
ocean home so you can donate them to
blathers so he can keep them captive in
tiny museum exhibits it's not only cruel
but bad for the environment which is
also not real because this is a video
game so technically it does not have an
environment is it okay to catch bugs in
Animal Crossing also no huge bummer
actually we're running out of activities
by the minute they do mention here that
it's disappointing that a game that has
villages from all different species from
elephants and ducks to deer and pigs
living and coexisting harmoniously with
humans yet fish and bugs are left out of
that they are disregarded as forms of
entertainment for the other villages in
this form of entertainment that is again
a video game frankly it is kind of
messed
the stewed wants a museum just full of
bugs and fish like I'm gonna let them
have that one think what if you put the
art in there you know they you can you
can make really cool odd and then you
can get like a QR code you can make it
online and you can scan it into the game
like that would probably actually be a
colon museum but I need something to
make me feel like I've accomplished
something and sometimes that's just a
big fish Josas fish don't belong in
tanks bugs don't belong in tiny cases in
a museum for other villages to go cat
your island should be a place where
wildlife is free to live without being
captured and exploited in a museum oh my
god I just read the next header I jumped
ahead do clams feel pain on your island
you can dig dig for clams here's why you
shouldn't
clams may look less animal like the
mammals but they still deserve
consideration and respect that is
actually true I have seen clams borrow
through sand before that is oh I didn't
mean open that nope
get me nope nope although it may be
unclear whether clams feel pain they
play a huge pot in the ecosystem in the
real world so we actually don't even
know if they feel pain but hey it's best
to be safe rather than sorry and not dig
for clams on your Island should I leave
the home it crabs in Animal Crossing new
horizons alone do you know what I think
it's gonna say I think it's gonna say
yes when you capture a hundred crab in
the game it says I call it a hermit crab
I think you wanted to be left alone they
did set themselves up for that one at
this moment the game demonstrates a
surprising self-awareness that we
shouldn't be bothering these animals and
taking them from their homes aren't
their homes
technically the shells in which they
live and thus you are just transporting
their home rather than taking them from
them think about that in real life
hammock crops can live for more than 30
years Pam what's the old crap what would
a vegan eat on a desert island okay now
I'm actually interested like nuts and
stuff probably like I guess vegans can
eat bugs I think you're gonna have it
have a bit of trouble playing survivor
like
naked and afraid is gonna be a tough
time for you now the whole world knows
the answer to the eternal question of
what a vegan waited on a desert island
fruit that makes sense
not sure why I went for nuts if you get
a recipe to build this doghouse
don't ya this is one of the most
important ethical questions that I've
encountered in Animal Crossing is should
I build this doghouse
at all oh my god as Tom Nook exploiting
Tom Nook is a tanuki a raccoon dog
raccoon dogs are often killed for this
this is a joke right because it's
actually pretty funny tom nooks family
may have been beaten anally electrocuted
to death
Gaston skinned alive cut him some slack
so he became a capitalist is that how it
works
listen I didn't know that about Tom Nook
but I still think he can go [ __ ] himself
I'm sorry that you were anally
electrocuted to death or your family was
despite to them being present in the
game for the most part but that sucks
stop making everything so expensive how
to spread animal rights through Animal
Crossing new horizons give your Island
an animal friendly utopian name like
vegan so customize your passport with a
phrase like hashtag and speciesism or
adopt don't shop or go vegan make custom
designs you didn't even try this come on
look at the differences in these let
this is bad OTT you should feel this is
bad and you should feel bad post a
bulletin to instruct your visitors to
leave wildlife alone as Junipero has a
zero tolerance policy on speciesism no
fishing no catching bugs respect to all
animals while visiting how much harder
would it make the game to be fed playing
this game as a vegan well nothing you
even need to eat the stuff that you
catch so that's a bit a bit of it
conundrum but I feel like it would be
significantly hotter like maybe if you
want to play animal crossing on some
kind of hardcore mode this is how you
get it Doug
what animal friendly ways can you enjoy
your island do animal friendly
activities when your friends come to
visit instead of fishing on catching
bugs like having a bonfire playing music
together under the stars or discovering
a secret beach together and that pretty
much sums it up actually yeah mostly you
can just kind of sit and discover a
beach so it's a game play limitation
well they seem to have actually played
the game at least who have gotten these
screen shots right because this is the
same character I think this person
actually actually did all this if you
made our island called sand UNEP arrow
which well that's what I'm assuming big
black Mara fan is black merit vegan
probably not not a lot like that you
gotta get rid of that too and I guess
those are your answers to the tough
ethical questions that the game presents
in case you're wondering such as the
clams feel pain and should I build this
doghouse and definitely is Tom milk
exploiting you no matter what happens to
you I don't think pulling a Tom Nick Tom
milk is really an excuse like huge
bummer about your family dude I didn't
know what do you is a raccoon dog
whoa that's a cute animal that's real
cute look at him huh how dare you be
that cute and try to steal on my [ __ ]
money